NOEL: Last time,
the push for perfect pastry...
Hooray!
..gave Rahul a handshake...
You are a dark horse, aren't you?
..and gave Briony Star Baker
for the first time.
Ooh, thank you!
- This is about celebration of pastry, and that is not a celebration of pastry. No, it is
- n't.
But it was Dan who left the tent.
Come on, mate. Never mind.
SANDI: This week... Oh.
..a Bake Off first as
eggs and butter are banished...
Baking's hard as it is.
..for Vegan Week.
Can we have a Kebab Week soon?
There's still pastry to be made...
I don't think that's soggy bottom.
..stiff peaks to achieve...
Good sign. Ooh.
..and delicate sponge to stack.
But one baker's dreams
are about to topple.
Ooh.
Ooh, it's... Oh, it's going!
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
NOEL: # I'm a happy cow now
because it's Vegan Week
# There's no dairy or meat
# Why don't you chop up a leek
because it's Vegan Week?
That is really good.
Did you write it yourself?
It's a kind of new kind of music.
I call it Moo Wave.
Oh, yeah.
That is a really happy cow.
Can't believe we got Paul and Prue
to agree to that.
I know.
I feel sorry for Prue, actually.
She's not the back end?
Yeah.
And Paul had beans for breakfast.
Not his usual sausage sandwich?
No, it's Vegan Week.
Yeah, the cow said.
# It's Vegan Week
# Chop up a leek! #
I genuinely never thought
that I would get Star Baker
so I can go now, happy. It's fine.
Back again, week seven.
Yeah, I can feel the tension.
Paul and Prue bringing out Vegan
Week on us, for the first time.
They are a dream, aren't they?
I had to do, like, internet searches
this week on vegetables because,
you know,
I just don't know this stuff.
Hello, bakers. Welcome to the tent,
and it's a Bake Off first -
it's Vegan Week.
So no meat, obvs, but also no eggs
or milk or butter or even honey.
I'll tell my mate Ralph.
He'll be well pleased.
Why? He's a bee. OK.
Er, so for your vegan Signature
Challenge, the judges would like
you to make eight savoury tartlets
with two different fillings.
So you need four tartlets with
one filling and four with
a different one.
Your tarts must be made with your
own variation of a vegan-friendly
shortcrust pastry that the judges
would never realise were vegan.
No problem at all.
You've got two hours to complete
your Signature Challenge.
On your marks...
..get set...
..bake!
It is weird being in the Bake Off
tent and there's no egg.
I would say we're running around
like headless chickens, but no.
Baking's hard as it is, let alone,
er, when it's vegan.
We set this challenge basically
because it's difficult.
Traditionally you would use butter,
you would use eggs to create
a beautifully short pastry,
but that isn't an option here.
So this is really going
to challenge the bakers
to create flavours,
to create textures.
The most important thing is that
these bakers deliver on flavour
and we know they can all do that.
Can they do it vegan style?
BIRDSONG
NOEL: If the bakers were sticking
to convention,
butter would be the key
to perfect shortcrust pastry.
Basically in a pastry,
you always need some fat.
..but with a butter ban, a delicate
balance of alternatives
is essential to provide rich flavour
and a golden finish.
So olive oil or coconut oil.
Coconut oil resembles butter
in many ways.
I really like the flavour of it.
Instead of butter I'm just using
vegetable shortening.
This is just a little bit of
turmeric and little bit of chilli.
Just have a little bit
of kick to it.
I have a bit of vegetable oil.
I also have some vegan margarine,
which I've got in there.
So I'm just bringing it
all together now.
This is flour, avocado oil,
I've also put some poppy seeds in.
Vegan baking can be as flavoursome
as normal baking, so it'll be
nice to prove that it can be done.
To prove her point, Briony's first
savoury tart will have a rich,
creamy filling made with vegan
goat's cheese and oat cream
while her second celebrates root veg
in a rosette sweetened with apple.
These tartlets are beginning
to sound a little bit like
dessert rather than savoury.
Oh, well, it's got the celeriac
and the sweet potato.
It's got mixed spice in as well.
So, no, it is, you know... Savoury.
It is savoury but it does, sort of,
have a slightly sweeter taste.
But Briony's enthusiasm for vegan
baking isn't shared with one baker.
I'm not really into Vegan Week.
It isn't my thing.
Every meal I have contains meat.
Can we have a Kebab Week soon?
Despite his misgivings,
Jon's given himself a lot to do,
making from scratch falafel,
hummus, purple mashed potato,
sauteed and baked mushrooms,
not forgetting his vegan pastry.
OK, so you're making pastry...
Yeah.
..and then you're making various
vegan little dishes
and plonking them one by one...
Yeah. Okey dokey.
Well, I mean,
you're certainly having a go.
You're doing a bit of everything.
I'm making a tart for the summer
and a tart for the winter.
The tart for the summer
is ratatouille.
Just reminds me of home, really.
Hopefully today we can prove
that no, vegan is not boring.
Manon's winter tart with flavours
taken from her flatmate's favourite
vegetarian pie, will be a luxurious
chestnut and mushroom filling.
So I want to talk to you,
French person... Yes.
..with no access to butter
or cream or milk or eggs.
I'm surviving.
You're surviving!
These pastry cases I'm going to put
in the fridge to chill.
If dough isn't chilled,
as with non-vegan pastry,
the results will be greasy
and misshapen.
Whatever you use instead of butter,
it still needs to be cold.
The theory's still the same.
Onto the filling.
Chopper's out.
Chopper's ready to go.
What is he doing?
So, first filling is called posto,
which is a very traditional
Bengali food item,
like something between pesto
and hummus.
And then it's gonna be topped with
some roasted vegetable rosettes.
Rahul's happy sticking to flavours
from home with his other filling,
inspired by the chickpea-based
Indian street food dish,
ghugni chat.
You seem, er, quite positive
this week.
I'm not sure it's positive. It's
just, like, counting my final days.
Let's not go that far. It's not
positive but it's not negative.
It's a step in the right direction.
I don't know.
By the end you're gonna be
sort of dancing around tent
with gay abandon. No?
Good luck with that.
NOEL LAUGHS
I'm caramelising the onions
with prosecco.
It's really nice, actually.
It's really tasty.
I'm making my falafel.
I've blitzed it down.
Still a little bit of texture to it,
which is what I'm looking for.
So hopefully these will crisp up
nicely in the fryer.
I have been testing these out
on my cousin and my sister.
They are both vegetarian
and they would love to go vegan,
so the last time I made them,
I had a soggy bottom on my tart
so they didn't eat them.
If she manages to perfect her vegan
pastry, Ruby's planning fillings
using butternut squash
as well as greens
cooked in a dairy-free
cheesy sauce,
given its flavour with
powdered nutritional yeast.
I've eaten yeast. Right. Doesn't
taste anything like cheese.
Well, have you eaten nutritional
yeast? It's, um, interesting.
I mean, I wouldn't eat it
just like this but...
No. Can I smell it?
Yeah, course you can.
Oh, it's quite nice.
Yeah. It gives it not a bad flavour.
I'm OK, thanks.
I'm trying to give it up.
It's slightly Parmesan-y.
Yes. OK. Well, good luck.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank YOU!
To create a creamy texture
for her fillings,
Kim-Joy is turning to tofu.
I'm doing a tofu kind of quiche.
It's like bean curd, isn't it?
What is it?
Yeah, I love tofu. It's, like,
one of my favourite things.
Just a block of tofu
and some soy sauce.
Kim-Joy's also using tofu
in her second tart
to create vegan mascarpone,
finished with an image of a star
of a previous Bake Off,
the squirrel, complete with nuts!
You know, squirrels are cool.
Yeah, I wouldn't say
I'm an animal person.
I haven't grown up around animals
or anything
and I'm scared of a
lot of animals, really. Ha-ha!
Pastry chilled
and with the clock ticking,
the next step is essential if the
tarts are to impress Prue and Paul.
If you don't want to have a soggy
bottom, which I had last week,
we are blind baking today.
You can either put some baking beans
or rice or something just to
hold it down.
Whoops!
Right, so I'll put them in
at 180 for ten minutes.
There you go. Blind baking.
I'll put them on
for ten minutes to start.
As blind baking begins...
I think I'm gonna run out
of time today.
..Jon's work is piling up.
I've let the pastry chill
and rest in the fridge
and now I'm just rolling it out.
So I'm about 15 behind
at the moment.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
You have one hour left.
Think you're treating the whole day
as a bit too much of a holiday.
It's Vegan Week. Who doesn't want
to relax? Yeah, fair enough.
Drink? Thanks.
Neat absinthe. Wow!
Oh!
So I'm making a vegan bechamel.
This is cashew milk.
I feel like it's the closest
consistency and taste to milk.
This is my roasted butternut squash.
I've snuck in some chilli flakes but
maybe I'll just add in a touch more.
I want it to be punchy.
Are you running out of time? Do you
want me to freeze time for you?
Oh, if you could.
Could you do that for me?
I can do that. I'm a Time Lord.
Reset the clock or something
that they're using.
You can do this.
HE HUFFS
Now I need to start making
the curry.
Chole kubani,
which is chickpea curry.
Something smells so good.
Sorry?
What's this mound?
Mound? Leave the mound alone!
What's the mound doing?
Is it resting?
It's just chilling.
It's like a creature.
If you're a vegan,
your mouth will be watering.
I'm just taking out the beans.
OVEN BEEPS
Ah! Oh, no!
Beans everywhere. So hot.
Doesn't really look
that good, to be honest.
I can't tell why.
I just have a feeling
it looks funny.
They look OK.
They've shrunk back a little bit
more than they would at home.
I'm going back in.
This is the second stage
of my blind baking.
So now this will help dry out
the bottom, hopefully, now that
I've removed the baking beans.
They are going in for, like,
another eight minutes.
How long have we got left?
Just deep frying my falafel.
Got some just gone in the fryer now.
They seem to be holding.
I'm making my hummus now.
This is basically plum chutney.
This is tamarind paste.
Like, tiny bit.
It's a very tart flavour.
This is for the tofu part.
Just add Indian black salt.
It smells, like, you know,
like sulphur.
Ha-ha! Um, yeah.
Gives sort of an eggyness.
Bakers, you have half an hour,
just half an hour. OK.
No, that's mine!
Straight through.
Too hot.
So there is a bit of shrinkage.
I hope that's cooked.
So that's looking OK.
I think they have a bit of colour.
I don't think that's soggy bottom.
They're nicely brown.
The only problem is, like,
they're not so even.
I'm just going to put
the fillings in next.
Trying to make a vegan tart
look pretty.
Basically, I feel they would say,
"Oh, it's a bit simple."
But French food is simple, right?
And it's delicious.
Who would have thought
you can get a cheese flavour
without actual cheese?
I am pleasantly surprised.
I'm just popping in the filling,
which is the caramelised onion and
then in the bottom is, like, a bit
of the goat's cheese alternative.
This is the plum chutney I made
earlier going in now.
This is my kubani, that's going
to go on the top.
What are these little guys?
These are mushrooms,
chestnuts and bechamel...
Wow. ..little tarts.
I like those little trays.
They're like little mouse beds.
Little mice beds, oh, yeah!
Little bed for mice.
Right, these are going back in.
And back in the oven.
Those will go in probably until
a few minutes before the end.
Just a little bit more.
Bye-bye!
Looking OK, actually.
Not too bad, but I'm really
rushing it today.
I think I've done a few
too many elements.
I don't know what's happened
to my filling.
I thought I'd done a lot
more than that.
It's supposed to be
quite filled out.
I've literally run out of filling.
I can imagine this is going to be
good for you, Vegan Week?
Hopefully, yeah. I feel like
everyone keeps saying that to me.
You look like you might know your
way around a vegan restaurant.
But you're not vegan, are you?
No!
No, but you just have
that air about you. Yeah.
I don't know whether you can put
hummus back in the oven
but we'll soon find out, won't we?
I really don't think I'll be getting
Star Baker this week.
Purple mashed potato.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
Just 15 minutes remaining.
Dropped them on the floor.
These are not even bloody cooked.
Just leave them in the oven
for as long as I can go.
Tarty.
OVEN TIMER BEEPS
Good.
I want to get them out the tins
but they're just too hot to handle
at the moment.
Ow, ow, ow!
Think I may have burnt my fingers.
Now we're just making sure that
they're looking good.
Let's think about how I am
going to decorate.
Just a little bit of yoghurt.
They look amazing.
Thanks, mate.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have five minutes left!
Five minutes. Dammit!
OK, I need to start
assembling now.
It is going to be really rushed.
Right, coming out now
whether it's cooked or not.
It's made of acetate so it's, like,
an invisible squirrel.
You don't taste
the paprika too much.
Just a little bit of chopped
coriander and chopped onion.
I had to make something pretty.
Buy a stamp and put it on top.
I'm just going to blowtorch them.
I didn't really think about this.
In my head it seemed like a great
idea but of course
the green stuff's burning.
Pastry case is not cooked.
What's the point of making them look
pretty if they're inedible?
That's not done very well but, with
all the others, it will look OK.
He's holding a little nut.
Bakers, you have one minute.
Just one minute.
One minute?!
One VEGAN minute.
Right bakers, your time is up.
That is the end of your first
vegan challenge.
Oh. Whatever.
I don't know what happened.
Just absolutely lost time.
I love the colour, though. It's so
beautiful. Give me a plus point.
Give me a plus point.
Yes. Yes.
The bakers' savoury vegan tartlets
now face the judgment of
Paul and Prue.
Hello. Hello, Manon. Hi, Manon.
So, we have the summer tartlet
which is a ratatouille
and then we have the winter
tartlet which is a vegan bechamel
with chestnut mushrooms
and chestnuts.
It does look very attractive.
The pastry looks nice and even.
It's well baked all the way through.
It's nice.
Cuts beautifully through.
It's very mild... Mm-hm, yeah.
..but it is very delicious.
Have you got coconut in there?
Mm-hm. In the pastry.
Coconut really works, doesn't it?
That is excellent.
A very good pastry.
I'm glad. OK, let's look at
this ratatouille one. Yes.
Mm. It certainly tastes like
the south of France.
The pastry's a bit hard, but it's
good and it's holding its shape.
Overall, you've done a very
decent job. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Thank you.
Consistent in colour.
The shapes are identical,
which is a good start. Yeah.
How did you get on with
the cheese mixture
because you put in
that nutritional yeast? Yes.
It tasted good. Fingers crossed
it comes across well.
Well, I can taste the broccoli
and I can taste the um...
Cheese? ..broccoli!
A bit underwhelmed, actually.
Right, OK.
I was expecting it to have
more flavour in that. Right, OK.
I mean, the pastry's nice and thin.
Yeah. It's crisp.
But the only thing you can
really taste is the broccoli
and a bit of chilli...
OK. ..at the back of your throat.
Let's have a go at the other one.
Yeah.
One thing that winds me up,
green on the top of tomato.
I just thought it looked better,
you know.
It looks really nice
without them anyway. Yeah.
Quite sweet.
And chilli.
Just a little bit.
Ha, I think a bit more than
a little bit!
Honestly, I only put in a touch.
I was, like, I don't want
to go in too much.
I think, overall, I get the sage.
Yeah.
I get that bit of heat, and then
nothing much else. OK. That's fine.
This one is like a pesto.
It's just garlic, coriander leaf,
cashew nut and poppy seed paste.
Lovely pastry. Very good flavours.
I wouldn't have put
that much filling in.
Maybe even half that
would have been plenty.
OK, let's try this one now,
shall we?
This one is a ghugni chaat
which is chickpea curry and
underneath there is a plum chutney
and caramelised onions.
You can see the pastry is crumbly
but it's holding together which
is the difficult thing. Thank you.
Fantastic.
Poetry.
Thank you.
Poetry?
It is beautiful.
Wow. Poetry.
Mm. It's so delicate.
The pastry melts in the mouth.
Crispy.
And a little hint of spice
in there as well.
But the filling with the chickpea
is fantastic.
Who would have thought
that was vegan?
It's almost buttery.
It's so delicious. It is.
Thank you, Rahul.
Thank you. Thank you.
WHISPERS: She said poetry.
You have some.
Rahul, do a dance or something.
Go on.
Rahul! Rahul!
Just feels a bit flexible.
Oh.
Flexible?
Flexible pastry.
I'm thinking, rubbery pastry.
Oh, no. A flexible tartlet.
It's like it's been overworked.
It's so weird,
the veg on the top is veg
but then you've got this apple
underneath which makes it sweet
so, no matter what you put on the
top, the apple will always win.
OK. It's an apple pie.
Dollop of creme fraiche and
it would be delicious! Oh! Sorry.
This looks better.
This is the poppy seed.
Gives it a bit of colour, too.
Yeah, it does.
Very nice and thin pastry.
I mean, that's amazing.
The onions are the sort of onion
you'd put on a hot dog. Right.
But the overall flavour
actually is all right.
I quite like the flavour.
I think the flavour's lovely.
I think there's too much onion.
OK.
Can I ask about the rubbery pastry,
or flexible?
Was it rubbery or was it OK?
Actually, the pastry on that
was all right. OK. Good.
Are your flexible alarm bells
ringing? Yeah.
Thank you.
Where's the rest of it?
Uh, I ran out of filling and I
drastically ran out of time as well.
I can see that.
Quite unfinished.
It's a bit undercooked under there.
Yes.
OK, let's have a look.
They are a little bit untidy
because they're not full, and
maybe you chose the wrong size.
They do look a bit of a mess.
PAUL LAUGHS
It's a bit gluey.
It is very rubbery, the pastry.
It's the flavour of the tomatoes
I don't particularly like,
it's very artificial.
It's just too heavy.
It's not good.
Let's have a look at the falafel.
The base isn't too bad.
Again, it doesn't look
wonderfully attractive, does it?
I quite like the flavour
of the falafel.
The pastry's still
a little bit rubbery.
The potato added to it
doesn't really bring a lot,
just a little bit of colour.
It's not bad.
It's all right, you know.
Both the flavours
are good but too strong.
But also the pastry is very pale
and it's really untidy.
This has caught you out
a little bit. Yeah.
It's not your thing, is it?
It's not my thing at all.
I would admit to that.
It's very, uh, neat. Very artistic.
Baked well.
Nice colour.
It's quite nice the, um, layers.
The coconut pastry.
It's amazing.
I think the flavours are great.
You've got the cooling
that comes from the tofu
before you hit the onion.
It's absolutely delicious.
I'd never have said
that would have gone together.
Yeah, I like that one.
Ah, thank you.
Remind me of this one again?
Um, so that's got tofu,
broccoli, onion, the tomato on top.
It's got a bit of Indian
black salt for the egginess.
That's delicious.
The balance of flavour is very good.
Again, the tofu's bringing that
little bit of coolness to it.
And the pastry's flaky.
It's buttery. Thank you.
Very good job on both of them.
Very good job. Looks good.
Um, hm...
On Vegan Week?
Go on, go on, go on! Oh.
That's really good. Well done.
Thank you.
APPLAUSE  I can't believe that.
If anyone was going to pull off
a Vegan Week, it was you. Ah.
Oh, my gosh.
VOICEOVER: I did not think
I would get a handshake.
It's more then relief after that.
It's extreme joy.
The vegan gods got to me.
They attacked me,
but I'm still smiling.
They were underwhelmed.
I was underwhelmed,
you've just got to kind of
pick yourself up and carry on.
NOEL: The bakers were able
to practise
for their Signature Challenge
but nothing can prepare them
for what lies ahead
in our first-ever Vegan Technical.
Hi, bakers. Welcome back
to your Technical Challenge
which today has been set for you
by Prue. Prue, any advice?
Trust me, trust yourselves
and it will work.
Ah, it's a sort of trust exercise.
Right, off you two go.
So, for your Technical Challenge
today, Prue would love you to make
a vegan tropical fruit pavlova.
The judges will be looking for
two perfectly piped vegan meringue
discs... No egg whites. Yeah.
..sandwiched and topped with coconut
pastry cream and tropical fruit.
The meringue must be
crispy on the outside
but also kind of marshmallowy
on the inside. Ah, lovely.
You've got two-and-a-half hours
to complete this challenge.
On your marks...
Get set... ...bake.
OK, we're in business.
I've made a pavlova.
Never made a vegan pavlova.
Little bit out of my comfort zone
with this, but there we go.
To make their vegan meringue,
the bakers will need to use
aquafaba instead of egg whites.
Oh.
Aquafaba is the preserved liquid
of cooked chickpeas.
Tried to make meringue
out of aquafaba before
but it didn't go very well.
Prue, a vegan pavlova? Yeah.
How does that work, then?
Well, you can't use any egg whites
so they've been given aquafaba.
What can go wrong?
It actually works like meringue
but it takes longer to whisk it
to a stiff peak.
The other great difference between
this and egg-white-based meringue
is that this is much more fragile.
It actually cuts a little bit like
a traditional meringue.
Nice and light.
Right.
The meringue is different.
It's very fragile.
Melts in the mouth. The overall
texture and taste is gorgeous.
Nice challenge, Prue.
Let's hope they rise to it.
OK.
# Dah, dah, dah, dah, dah, dah! #
First stage is whisk the aquafaba,
medium speed, until foaming.
I'm sure it's going to taste
everything but chickpea.
Chickpea juice pavlova? Hm.
I like chickpeas in their
own right... Yeah. Well, then...
..but when they pretend
to be meringue, I'm not sure!
I find it amazing that
someone sat there and thought,
I'm going to whisk the hell
out of some chickpea juice today.
I have never tried it before
so I'm not sure yet.
Increase the speed to high
and whisk to stiff peaks.
I've just added the sugar
one tablespoon at a time.
I don't know enough about it
to know whether you can over
or underwhisk it, like eggs.
When you bring in
a normal meringue stiff peaks,
you can tip the bowl over your head.
Essentially, you should be able
to do the same with the aquafaba.
Is that a meringue consistency?
I'm pretty happy.
It's quite thick and glossy.
It is peaked but it was,
like, peakier before.
So I don't know
if I overdid it a bit.
It's holding its shape.
Good sign.
I'm going to do it again.
It won't take too long.
Then you have to spoon the mixture
into a large piping bag
fitted with the star nozzle
and pipe two 20-centimetre discs
with a decorative edge.
Right, let's see
what this pipe's like.
Doesn't look like bean water at all.
Um.
Yeah, it seems all right.
It could maybe be a bit stiffer
but I think that's the thing
with aquafaba.
It feels pretty much the same,
if I'm being honest,
as a normal meringue.
I don't really know
what do to with the edges.
Not the easiest stuff to work with.
You know what? Who doesn't like
a little bit of spikey?
That'll do.
I just want to pipe it now.
I just can't do Technicals.
I really hate it.
OK. Now we're going
to put it in the oven.
The instructions say
bake till crisp and dry
and remove from the oven
and dry it completely.
Meringue needs to cook for
a long time on a low heat.
Definitely baking it
for about an hour minimum.
I'm putting it for one hour.
It might even take longer.
My meringues for the aquafaba,
I do for 75 minutes.
They want it crispy on the outside
and soft in the middle.
I don't actually know how long
to bake a vegan pavlova for.
It takes the same as a normal
meringue, I think.
Um, I'm just going to follow
what everyone else does.
I think it's a pretty
tough challenge.
You've had one hour. You've got
an hour-and-a-half. That's a fact.
Five, make the coconut pastry cream.
I've not made vegan coconut
pastry cream before, I have to say.
This is a new one.
There's no instructions on
how to make the pastry cream.
It just says, make it.
How should I do this?
I'm going to follow what we do
when we do a creme patissiere.
NOEL: For this vegan
pastry cream recipe,
the rich taste
traditionally provided by eggs
comes from coconut milk,
and its thickness from cornflour.
Bring it to the boil. Give it a
whisk. Add your sugar. Mix that in.
Flavours. You always smash 'em
with the flavours, don't you?
Yeah, not too much today, though.
Come on, use the force now. Yeah?
Yeah. The force is
strong with this one. Yeah.
Punch Paul in the face
with flavours. Yeah, I will.
I don't think it can go any thicker,
to be honest with you.
Stir in the desiccated coconut.
Like, when you do a custard.
Keep on stirring.
The pastry cream's kind of, um,
slightly, weird.
Cool and chill.
Bakers, you have
half-an-hour left.
Oh, what are we doing?
Feels nice and firm.
It's getting a bit there
on the outside
but it's not actually crisp yet.
Should I get it out? I don't know.
We have two-and-a-half hours
and it's not for nothing.
So, the longer I can leave
my meringue inside.
I think I have to switch it off now
otherwise it's not going to
get cooled and cooked.
I might just turn the oven off
and let it dry out in there.
I'm going to get this out, I think.
I'm going to wait until it cools
a little bit more.
Turn it out. Pull it nicely.
OK.
Ugh!
OK, that doesn't look very good,
does it?
No good. Got to put that back in.
I don't really know how long
it's been in the oven.
Maybe needs a bit more crisping.
OK, what am I doing?
I need to melt some white chocolate.
It tastes like normal chocolate.
Obviously you need enough time
at the end to chill
and put the chocolate and build it.
I'm a bit worried actually because
it has to set, and it's quite hot.
So I think I have to work
pretty fast now.
OK, I think I'm going
to take them out
because you want it to be chewy,
it's a pavlova.
I'm just going to take it out now.
Whatever happens, happens.
I think that's pretty good.
Could be probably neater
on the old piping.
I'm really scared about
turning it upside down.
Ugh.
Just grab this out.
It's really so delicate. Ooh.
I'm a bit scared about
putting the chocolate on.
OK. It is fragile but that's what
it's meant to be like, isn't it?
I'm trying to use the chocolate
to fill some of the gaps.
Don't know whether to put
that in the freezer.
God, this is terrifying. I feel
like they're dissolving almost.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
15 vegan minutes!
I'd better get a wiggle on.
I'm going to finish the cream.
Beat the coconut yoghurt and passion
fruit seeds into set pastry cream.
Mm. Gloop.
That's going to be
very interesting.
And then pass through a sieve.
This actually looks like
pastry cream.
I mean, that does taste delicious.
I have to take them out now.
I don't have time otherwise.
Assembly time.
Place one of the meringue shells
base-side-down on the cakestand
and spread over half
of the pastry cream.
Mine looks really bad compared
to everybody else's.
Just wondering
how I'm going to decorate this
because decorating's not my thing.
I'm going to try to make
some little stars.
I don't know what I'm doing!
Top with fruits and
toasted coconuts.
Going in with some passion fruit.
Yeah, I'm going to cover up
my dodgy meringue.
Pavlova is all about
mixing the fruits together.
There isn't really a method.
Just looks really old-school.
Place the other meringue
on top and repeat.
Mine is very sad looking.
Is that all of it?
Please say I've got enough!
Argh!
Bakers, your time is up!
Oh, dear.
Please place your pavlovas
behind your photographs
on the gingham tablecloth.
You totally nailed that.
I did nail that.
Prue and Paul are looking for
two decoratively piped discs
of vegan meringue filled and topped
with coconut pastry cream
and tropical fruit.
They have no idea
whose vegan pavlovas are whose.
OK, let's start with this one.
We did ask for decorative meringue
not just flat discs.
There's been an issue, whether it
broke up when they were moving it,
you know... Yeah.
..it is quite delicate.
Let's have a look at it, shall we?
Yeah.
The meringue's not bad, I just think
they weren't delicate enough
when they were removing it
off the paper.
The fruit doesn't look
quite so generous.
Pavlova's indulgent... Yeah.
..and that doesn't look indulgent.
Right, that is very
impressive piping
and the meringue was
absolutely properly whipped.
The decoration's indulgent.
It's that pile, isn't it?
Marshmallowy inside. Crispy
on the outside. I like that one.
There's a lot of textures going on
in that one. It's very neat.
Now, this next one, again,
lazy with the piping again.
It's cracked a bit there.
There is definition there, though.
Pastry cream is absolutely
delicious. It's very runny, though.
It does mean
the meringue will soften.
OK, moving on.
Lost a little bit of definition
on the bottom. Yeah.
I quite like the way the baker
has thought about making
one bigger than the other.
Mm. Meringue's good.
Crispy. Marshmallowy.
I love the definition in this one.
Yeah. Nice and equal.
Hardly any cracks.
Let's have a look in this.
The meringue's cooked well.
It is very full. Colourful as well.
Moving on to this last one.
Good attempt at trying to create
something a little bit different
but they've lost the definition,
haven't they?
However, it still looks rather nice.
Right.
The meringue's very good.
It's actually quite well cooked
all the way through as well.
It's nice, isn't it?
Very nice.
NOEL: Prue and Paul will now rank
the pavlovas from worst to best.
In sixth place is this one.
Whose is this? Me.
Kim-Joy, it was just a little bit
boring on the piping.
In fifth place is this one.
Who's that? It's me. Briony.
It's all a little bit flat.
Yeah.
Jon is fourth.
Ruby's third.
So, in second place... is this one.
Pretty good, actually, Manon.
You managed to create a fantastic
bake of the meringue
all the way through.
Thank you.
Which leaves, of course, Rahul.
CHEERING
Thank you.
Rahul, your pavlova had everything.
It's got beautiful definition,
silky-smooth pastry cream,
lots of fruit, looks indulgent,
tastes great. Bravo.
I can't believe it.
VOICEOVER: This is the first time
I came first in Technical.
I mean, I made something
and the judges liked it,
that's a very good thing.
I just get confused
I think in Technicals.
I get all flustered. But I'm trying.
I'd have taken fourth in Technical
the first week, but not this week.
Fourth is in the middle but it's
the bottom half of the middle,
so I'm looking pretty dangerous now.
NOEL: One challenge remains before
Paul and Prue decide
who will make the quarterfinal.
Paul, I have to ask you,
Vegan Week was something
you were looking forward to?
Not particularly.
Having said that,
and seeing how the bakers
have dealt with it so far,
it is possible to create
some great-tasting food.
Coconut oil seems to be
a revelation.
Vegan... Yeah, it's delicious
and the coconut oil pastry
was really good.
This is a tricky one.
Overall, I think you're looking
at Manon and Rahul
as potential Star Bakers.
All the others are in a little bit
of trouble going into the
Showstopper.
I think less so Kim-Joy because
she did so well in the Signature.
Is there a Paul Hollywood
vegan cookbook?
Nope.
LAUGHTER
Hello, bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
For your Showstopper Challenge
today,
the lovely Paul and Prue would love
you to make a vegan celebration cake
that could be the centrepiece
at a party,
or a happening, if it's the '60s.
The judges are looking
for an inventive,
visually exciting celebration cake
made from plant-based ingredients
only.
They can be any shape you like,
so from classically tiered
to novelty,
but they must be utterly delicious.
You've got four hours.
On your marks...
Get set... Bake!
Biggest concern is just making sure
I get everything done in time.
So I try and work as fast
as I can right now. Yeah.
Feeling the pressure today, totally.
Didn't do well in the Signature.
Bottom of the middle
of the pack in Technical.
OK, yes, it's a vegan cake, but
there shouldn't be any compromise.
PRUE: These are very experienced,
good bakers.
Every one of them will have made
dozens and dozens of
excellent cakes.
But they probably will have made
them with eggs and butter.
They have to make a cake
that is just as tender,
just as beautifully risen
but without them.
So that means you could use
bicarbonate of soda...
A bit of vinegar helps
with the rise.
But they have to get it into
the oven fast,
otherwise those
bubbles come and go.
PAUL: We want colour,
we want personality,
but above all I'd like
something that tastes amazing.
When I come to judging this,
I'm going to judge it exactly the
same as I would a non-vegan cake.
I expect it to be that good.
SANDI: Traditionally in a sponge,
eggs and butter are manipulated to
give flavour, height and texture.
With none in the tent,
it is essential the bakers find
harmony in the alternatives
if they are to produce a
flavoursome, well-structured bake.
The wet ingredients - I'm using
a mixture of oil
and dairy-free margarine.
Vegan margarine actually
works surprisingly well.
Like, you can't really notice
much of a difference.
We have some coconut oil,
then you have some soya milk.
The wet ingredients are
coconut milk, sunflower oil,
coconut extract.
It's difficult not using
eggs and butter.
Like a lot of vegan cakes,
it's more about speed.
Good morning, Kim-Joy. Hello.
So, Kim-Joy,
tell us all about your Showstopper.
I am doing, um, a fox-themed
birthday cake for a friend.
Fox-themed? Fox-themed.
Fox-themed.
He likes foxes and that's like...
You know, people say they're their
spiritual animal and stuff.
His spiritual animal's a fox?
Yeah.
NOEL: Decorated with her second
woodland creature of the week,
this time made from vanilla
biscuits,
Kim-Joy's two-tiered cake
will be flavoured with lavender and
lemon curd, inspired by her travels.
Those flavours came
from when I went on holiday,
I had a lavender-lemon curd
ice cream.
And it really was
my favourite ice cream ever.
I just feel like I wanted
to use those flavours.
So this is an apple spiced cake.
You know like you do carrot cake?
The carrots will give it the
moisture and the deliciousness.
We're looking for kind of
the same texture.
The bottom tier will be
a lemon sponge.
The top tier is a chocolate sponge.
I stupidly thought that making
two different flavours
would be a real good idea.
I just basically got chocolate and
orange to celebrate
one of my favourite sitcoms,
and the cake is called
Only Fools Eat Horses.
SANDI: Hoping to salvage his Vegan
Week, Jon's take on the Trotters
will be a vegan chocolate fudge cake
with orange curd icing,
topped with a meringue pineapple,
finished with sheepskin buttercream
and a hint of leopard print.
Hopefully, it'll show Del Boy's
exquisite taste in a vegan cake.
Fancy Del Boy
having a vegan cake.
OK, so bicarb reacts with
vinegar and give the fluffiness
to the sponginess to the cake.
You need to move quite quick cos
you can start hearing it bubble.
It's not coming together as well
as it did at home, as always.
Time to pour it in.
The reaction's happening right now.
You want that reaction
really in the oven.
Yeah, in.
Uh!
This is going in 160.
20 minutes at 180.
15 minutes and then I'll check them.
I'm just hoping they bake OK.
So they will go in
for about 45, 50 minutes.
So that's one big job done.
Hi, Briony.
OK, Briony, tell us, what's the
whole theme behind your cake?
It's for my little brother
who turned 30 last year,
because he can't eat dairy,
so he eats a lot of vegan food.
The cake I made him for his
birthday wasn't as pretty
or as lovely as it should have been,
so this is the cake
that I wish I made him.
It's a bit girlie cos it's got roses
on it, but I don't think he'd mind.
NOEL: In a nod to
her brother's love of coffee,
Briony's making a mocha cake
decorated with hazelnuts,
piped chocolate roses
and laced with fresh raspberries.
You've chosen quite a lot of rich
things, like the mocha,
the chocolate, the hazelnut.
These are the overriding flavours
and I don't think we're really
going to tell much difference
between a vegan and a non-vegan.
Well, hopefully. That's the idea.
I'm making my fake buttercream.
Yeah, buttercream
with no butter and no cream.
So it's just vegetable shortening,
icing sugar.
What is that made of?
What do you think it is?
Everything seems
to be made of chickpea.
Literally everything is made
of chickpea. Literally everything.
No chickpea in this.
This is buttercream.
I have used some vegan butter...
SHE LAUGHS
How do you cope with him?
He's quieter like that.
So these are all natural colours,
so we have matcha for the green,
turmeric for the yellow,
beetroot powder for the pink.
So these are going to be piped
buttercream flowers.
SANDI: Manon's flowers will be
wrapped around
a three-tiered spiced apple cake.
Each tier will be made up of
three layers of sponge.
Yes. We're going for a big cake.
I'm concerned about time already.
HE SIGHS
Good morning, Rahul! Hiya.
What are you doing for
your vegan celebration cake?
This is basically a tribute to
my grandma.
My grandfather died in '84.
In India, quite a lot of time
when husband die, uh,
wife give away quite a lot of
different foods,
so my grandmother didn't have
eggs or meat
for the rest of her life
after my grandfather died.
So I've never seen her eating
a cake.
So it is kind of a tribute for her.
NOEL: Rahul's honouring his
grandmother
with two tiers of sandwiched coconut
and chocolate sponges,
decorated with chocolate shards
and soaked in a coconut drizzle.
It's a beautiful idea.
Yeah, thank you.
I'm very close to my grandma.
Yeah, I love my grandma.
She's not here any more, but
she loved me a lot. I mean, yeah.
SANDI: Rahul's not the only one
celebrating cherished memories
of family.
This cake is inspired by,
and it's for, my cousin.
This is a really fond memory that
we both have of a day out
with our grandad when we were really
young, and it's so simple.
It's just a day that we had with
our grandad
and we ate loads of ice creams, and
it seemed like the best day ever.
SANDI: Ice cream flavours are at the
heart of Ruby's celebration cake,
which she's hoping will keep her in
the tent for another week.
She's stacking three layers
of chocolate sponge
on top of three layers of lemon,
sandwiched with fresh raspberries
and drizzled in chocolate.
Are you dowel-ing it or...?
Yeah, I'll have dowels in there
because it's quite a tall cake
so I want to make sure it looks
all nice and sturdy.
I don't want any, um, wonky cakes.
Yeah, I'm going to get them
out now, I think.
Ta-dah! Good.
They're looking OK. There's
little cracks on the top
but it's happened already
so I can't change it.
Looking cakey.
Cracky but cakey.
Yeah, they look good. They have had
a little bit of a rise,
which is what we were looking for.
Yeah, they look good.
Just checking them all.
Being a bit paranoid.
It is baked.
And look, it's really spongy.
It's a proper cake.
It holds quite nicely, so it's quite
moist but it's not too stodgy.
Quite claggy.
Really don't know what's
gone wrong with those.
Oh, I'm overshooting!
Bakers, you're halfway through.
You're halfway...
Oh, yes! 2-2! 2-2!
Right, I can get on with my sugar
syrups and my ganache
and a million other things.
Oh!
This is my raspberry jam. Works
really nicely, cos raspberries
go well with chocolate.
Raspberries go well with coffee.
They go well with hazelnut.
It goes well with all of it.
It's a very sharp lemon curd.
I don't know if they'll like the
tartness or not. I hope they do.
NOEL: When finished, each cake
should demonstrate decorating
techniques fit for a celebration.
They don't all have to be the same.
That's the beauty of flowers,
you know, they're never perfect.
It's going to look so pretty.
I'm just making the buttercream
roses
because roses are
favourite flowers of my grandma.
Hey, lovely boy. Hiya.
You could sound a bit more excited
when I turn up. Sorry?
No. OK.
OK,
so now I need to do the biscuits.
It's, like, basically coconut oil
and flour
and they're quite quick to bake.
My yellow meringue. The yellow's to
make it look like a pineapple.
NOEL: I like the smells.
What is that? Mocha? Mocha, yeah.
You know who likes mocha, don't
you? Who? Paul. No way.
Yeah.
I often rustle up Paul a mocha.
Do you?
OK. Fun time.
So, this is my favourite moment,
decorate and icing the cake.
I'm drenching my sponges
in a sugar syrup.
It's a good way to keep
your cakes moist.
I think the cake should be quite
moist anyway,
but obviously the chocolate doesn't
have any coconut flavouring in it,
so this is like a sugar, water
and coconut extract.
I'm putting the jam in between
each layer
and then there'll be ganache
round the outside.
I'm just sort of piping circles
of buttercream around
and then I'm pouring orange curd
in but it's nowhere near set,
so hopefully the buttercream
will keep it in there.
Buttercream's a bit
too stiff at the minute.
This is a vegan ganache.
So it is vegan dark chocolate
with a coconut cream.
Just gotta get it nice
and smooth as possible.
I'm doing that sort of, like,
semi-naked cake.
I love naked cake.
I think it looks really cool.
That isn't looking pretty.
It broke when I was icing it.
So I'm just going to take it off.
I don't know what happens
but I look at you and I just
want to crush these.
Bakers, you have half an hour.
Half an hour.
See my artistic skills
coming out now.
I'd love to get
the presentation right.
I'm probably the opposite
of Kim-Joy.
Yeah, I think I like the decorating.
It's probably my
favourite part of it.
Raspberries on the dark chocolate.
I think they look so pretty.
Everyone's is looking
really good at the minute.
I really want this one to look good.
It looked really good at home.
Oh, I love that. I want a pair
of trousers made out of that.
So I'm going to start assembling.
Oh...
That's terrifying.
OK,
which side is the least bad side?
It's just extremely wonky
for some reason.
I'm going to put all
the decoration this way.
I don't know whether I can finish
my decoration or not.
I just need to try. That's it.
Yeah. Good.
Oh, please.
I've got the wonkiest cake going.
I'm so scared that he's not going
to be able to sit on top of it.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes.
15 minutes.
Maybe if I have it facing
this way, you can't see a wonk.
I'm quite happy with that, actually.
That'll do. That'll do, Donkey.
Looks fine.
Yay. It looks pretty.
It looks fantastic. Thank you.
You've got a leaning situation.
Where shall I stand
so that it doesn't tip over?
B, can you help me put this on?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm scared. You've got dowels
in there, haven't you? Yeah.
Then it'll be fine. I don't think
that's going to...
Uh-oh.
Cake stand is Del Boy's suitcase.
Done what I set out to
achieve, I think.
Really starting to panic.
It's OK, you're doing good.
Bakers, you only have five minutes
left.
SANDI: Just five minutes.
Right, I've got some dowels. Yeah,
it needs to be a bit taller.
Really nice.
There? Just a little bit... taller
Jon. Taller, Jon. Go.
NOEL: Come on, kids.
You can do this, Rahul.
I don't think that's going to stay.
It's literally, like,
caved in at the back.
Bakers,
you only have one minute left.
OK, do you need help?
It's OK, it's OK. You've got this.
Think I may have done Del Boy proud.
He'd try and sell it for a couple of
quid, wouldn't he, anyway?
Look at the state of it.
What an absolute state.
It looks terrible. Melting
and breaking from everywhere.
There is it. It's done.
Oh, that's it, guys.
Oh, I'm so wounded.
I'm sorry, bakers,
but your time is up.
SHE EXHALES
Right, bakers,
off you go, my lovelies.
That is the end of all
your vegan challenges.
Well done.
It just needs to go in the fridge.
Oh, that looks so good.
Mine's bowing out at the bottom now.
Oh, man. That was awful.
What did you use to stick
your cake together?
Buttercream, mainly.
SANDI: It might taste amazing.
Oh...
Ooh.
Ooh, it's...
Oh, it's going, it's going.
BLEEP. It's going to fall.
Oh, God. No.
I think your cake's just fallen.
Oh... BLEEP. Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
The bakers' vegan celebration cakes
now face the judgment of
Paul and Prue.
Briony, would you like to bring
your Showstopper up, please?
Briony, tell us about
your Showstopper.
So this is my hazelnut mocha
vegan cake with raspberry jam,
chocolate ganache, and then
there's some buttercream roses.
Well, I must say it looks
as neat as a pin.
Thank you.
I do like the look of that.
It's very elegant. Thank you.
Solid piece, and sits on the plate
without a crumb out of place.
Perfect three layers.
Mm.
The raspberry lifts everything,
because the mocha's very delicate.
I quite like it.
It's different.
I think you've done a good job,
actually... Mm.
Thank you. ..on its flavour,
texture, look.
It's a very nice cake.
Thank you. Well done, Briony.
It looks a bit sad.
It's knocked off.
It's very, erm,
crude in its decoration.
I quite like the animal print.
It looks like Bet Lynch's
skirt, actually.
What's in it?
It's a chocolate and orange cake
with chocolate sponge,
with orange curd in there,
and orange buttercream.
Jon, I think your layers are
really good. They're even.
It's a bit claggy.
I enjoy that flavour.
The orange in there's really nice
and sharp, carries it through.
I mean, it looks hideous, but
the flavour of it is very good.
Thank you. Cheers.
For me there's a bit too much orange
curd, but I think it's a good cake.
Thank you.
It's absolutely beautiful.
Very delicately done.
The naked cake is perfect.
When you get it right, Manon,
you really get it right, don't you?
Let's have a look inside, shall we?
Very neat, coming out.
Looks a bit puddingy.
It does, doesn't it?
It's really heavy.
Yeah.
Gluey.
It's not good.
Looks great, tastes awful.
Oh, really?
It is like an underbaked cake,
and it's quite rubbery as well,
actually.
It's like it's been overworked,
it's been overmixed.
Apple, I'm certainly not getting.
It's not a good cake at all.
That's a shame.
I love the colours.
I think they're very pretty
and subtle and unusual.
If I was going to relate a cake
to anyone in this tent,
I'd certainly relate
this cake to you.
The decoration is exquisite.
You've gone to the trouble
of making biscuits too.
It's standing up.
I think it's a nice-looking cake.
Thank you.
Now, this is lavender sponge? Yes.
Very good.
Mm.
Quite powerful lavender.
It is very pudding-like, isn't it?
Mm.
But nevertheless, I think
the balance between lavender,
which is very brave of you to do...
Phew.
..and the lemon,
which is again quite sharp,
work together very well.
Well done. I think
that's a really nice cake.
Ah, thank you very much.
Well done, Kim-Joy.
What happened?
When I constructed them
it was standing OK, then
I put it in the fridge and then I
left, and when I came back it was...
OK, let's have a look at it.
I might not put the drizzle as well
because I put a coconut drizzle,
which actually might have softened
the whole thing up.
Well, I think I can see your
problem. I think it could be
the drizzle. It's the drizzle
just makes it really soggy, yeah.
It's weakened the whole thing,
and you can see where
it's compressed in the middle,
and the whole thing's just
given way. Collapsed, yeah.
The chocolate is good. The coconut
one has just been drenched.
It's too much.
It actually tastes
too much coconut, too.
You were trying too hard to get
too much flavour into something
that was already big.
You had enough flavour in
without any drizzle.
That's just a pity.
It's gonna be a bit difficult
to put the best side forward.
So... let's go that way.
Because it's a collapsed mess,
it looks...
I mean, it looks like a disaster.
Yeah. Right...
I had to put in quite a few dowels
at the end so you'll probably
hit a lot of, ah...
Wow.
It's more dowel than cake. Yes.
Do you envisage them
being eaten together?
No. Either the chocolate
or the lemon.
Right.
Mm.
I like that.
Lemony, coconutty.
Delicious.
I like the lemon cake.
I like the flavour of
the raspberries in there as well.
And actually, I like
the chocolate one too.
They're actually both
very good cakes.
I think you got it
the wrong way around. Yeah.
I think if you'd put the chocolate,
which is a lot more stable than
the lemon... Yeah. ..underneath,
it would've been fine.
Yeah, I think the sponge in
the lemon one, it was really soft.
So it was just a bad judgment.
I'm scrapping at
the positives at the minute.
I'm in very dangerous territory.
Vegan Week.
I mean, Paul, you weren't happy
before we started.
How do you feel now?
A bit disappointed with people.
Mainly Manon.
It was an awful cake and yet
it was exquisite to look at.
OK, so is it going to be that
the look is one thing
but the taste is the paramount
thing, because Ruby's...?
Exactly. I would have given Ruby's
higher marks than Manon's because
Ruby's was edible.
It was delicious.
But you can't discount her from
the possibility of leaving us.
At the end of the day it failed,
and it was her fault.
I think we've got a real problem
with the judging.
Coming into the Showstopper,
we'd put Briony, Ruby, Jon,
and obviously you had to put Kim-Joy
in there because she came last
in the Technical,
in a little bit of trouble.
Briony's saved herself because
that cake was pretty good.
The hazelnut, the mocha.
It was a very neat-looking cake.
Kim-Joy saved herself and then some.
We put Rahul and Manon up
for Star Baker.
But Rahul has had a hideous...
Well, you'd say that but actually
his cake, the flavour,
actually wasn't that bad.
At the same time, I have to put
Kim-Joy up as Star Baker as well.
Her fox cake looked great,
I thought. Beautiful colours.
And you know what?
The flavour was good.
So I think what you're looking at,
Kim-Joy and I would say,
you have to say Rahul still up
for Star Baker.
And I would say Ruby and Jon...
Bumping along the bottom. Yes.
Well, well done, bakers.
Really successful Vegan Week.
Ironically, the Star Baker
is someone who
brought animals into the tent
but in a whimsical, colourful way.
Star Baker this week is Kim-Joy.
Yay! Aww!
Foxy baker! Foxy!
Aww!
Ah, man.
I have to say this gets tougher
and tougher every week because
we are so fond of all of you,
and it is a really a horrible job.
Uh, but I'm afraid
the person who's going home is...
..Jon.
I'm so sorry.
OK.
You did such a great job.
Immensely proud of
what I've achieved.
To make it past week one,
I was immensely proud.
But to make it to week seven,
absolutely amazing.
I think you're brilliant.
Cheers, anyway.
It's been amazing. Really has.
Oh, Jon.
Ah!
I am sad to see Jon go.
He's got such personality.
He's so different from
everybody else.
He's actually a very good baker
and his flavours are always
very, very good.
Well done, my darling.
Congratulations. I didn't think
that would happen.
Star Baker of Vegan Week?
I can't believe I'm saying
those words!
Kim-Joy has done really well
to win Star Baker.
I told ya. I told ya!
Overall she was certainly
the best on Vegan Week.
Oh, my God.
Are they sure? Like, positive?
Vegan Week was hard.
Really, really hard.
Group hug. Well done, everyone.
Five left now.
Quarterfinal coming up.
I have no idea
who's going to win this thing.
Next time...
Shoomy-shoomy-shoomy-shoomy.
...the tent turns Nordic...
Danish Week!
...in our first-ever Danish Week...
No time for tears. Got to chop.
..with a Signature that bares all...
Do you want to give me a little tip?
...a scandalous
Scandinavian Technical
and ginormous...
..Nordic pastry Showstoppers.
This is the hardest
challenge we've done.
But who will make it through...
Ooh!
...to the semifinal of
The Great British Bake Off?
Subtitles by Red Bee Media